[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieses video möchte ich mit einem
kleinen quiz für euch beginn bietet
google jetzt nicht danach dann die
antwort steht der titel des videos die
auch immer ich wette ihr hattet vorher
keinen lassen schimmer dass das teuerste
land der welt angola
jetzt mal ehrlich denn wenn man über die
größten orte dieser welt spricht haben
die meisten leute new york hongkong oder
zürich sind aber weit gefehlt die
teuerste stadt der welt nur an da die
hauptstadt angolas eines afrikanischen
landes
falls du dir eine wohnung in luanda
mieten wollte ist konntest du locker mal
mit 5000 dollar miete pro monat rechnen
ist dir das so teuer dann musst du halt
woanders sparen zum beispiel beim essen
für mehr als fast food wird er da wohl
nichts übrig bleiben ok wie wär's mit
einem big mac der kostet in london nur
schlappe 19 dollar na dann kochst du dir
doch lieber selbst was leckeres daheim
zum beispiel nach einem rezept aus dem
internet ach ja die rechnung des
internetproviders nur 300 dollar pro
monat ein schnäppchen nicht wahr
[Musik]
ok bis beiseite was zur hölle geht in
angola vorsicht ist da ein land
plötzlich ohne dass wir es bemerkt
hätten extrem reich geworden ihr habt
sicher schon befürchtet dies ist hier
nicht der fall
zwar ist die republik angola eines der
wichtigsten erdölexportierenden länder
das darin zb sogar katar überholt hat
aber trotzdem hat mehr als die hälfte
der bevölkerung angolas keinen zugang zu
sauberem trinkwasser
zwei von drei kindern leiden unter
mangelernährung
eines von sechs stirbt vor erreichen des
fünften lebensjahres
gleichzeitig am anderen ende des
spektrums eine der reichsten frauen
dieses planeten
isabel dos santos die tochter des
ehemaligen präsidenten josé eduardo dos
santos und jetzt ein tier wahrscheinlich
schon was hier vor sich geht genau
angola ist eines der weltweit
korruptesten länder tatsächlich war es
schauplatz eines der gigantischsten
wirtschaftlichen fiaskos in dem viele
firmen milliarden von dollar verloren
haben
[Musik]
das alles hört sich für dich
wahrscheinlich nicht besonders
überraschend an
schließlich ist angola ein land der
dritten welt
allerdings steht hier trotzdem eine
bohrende frage wie hat es dieses land
geschafft eine so bizarre
wirtschaftsstruktur mit der extremen
preisausschlägen hinzubekommen und
wichtiger auf welche weise hält das
regime das ganze land unter kontrolle
keine angst wir werden heute alle diese
fragen beantworten aber vorher werfen
wir einen blick in die geschichte
[Musik]
blutdiamanten und diplomatie zunächst
müssen wir uns da gegenwärtigen dass die
meisten afrikanischen länder früher mal
kolonien waren europäischen großmächte
wie portugal belgien frankreich hielten
den großteil des kontinents über lange
zeit besetzt zwangen ihn regel auf und
behandelten die einheimischen die
sklaven angola war da keine ausnahme
bis 1975 verdiente portugal einen
reibach durch die ausbeutung der
dortigen diamantenminen dann entließ
portugal angola allerdings in die
eigenständigkeit getrieben durch die ul
und das schlechte gewissen der eigenen
bevölkerung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nun stellte sich die frage was passiert
wenn aus einer kolonie ein
eigenständiger staat wird wer übernimmt
die regierungsgeschäfte nachdem die
europäischen kolonialherren sind nun
anstatt diese fragen in allgemeinen und
freien wahlen zu beantworten bildeten
die verschiedenen angolanische stämme
verschiedenen fronten und starteten
einen bürgerkrieg
dieser konflikt dauerte 25 jahre und er
war derart grausam
das ist bis heute viele völlig
unbedrängt barre landstrich an angola
gibt da diese mit landminen verseucht
sind jetzt fragst du dich natürlich wie
können sich ein solch armes land so
viele waffen leisten nun die antwort
liegt in den bereits erwähnten diamanten
alle kriegsparteien verkauften davon so
viel ist so ging und kauft man dafür
waffen auch so viele wie nur möglich
und er lieferte ihnen all diese waffen
nun nach 1976 nachdem der echte
bürgerkrieg ausgebrochen war gab es zwei
parteien die nationale union für die
völlige unabhängigkeit angolas kurz
mieter sie dominierte den süden des
landes und wurde von südafrika china und
in geringem maße auch durch die usa
unterstützt damals war der kalte krieg
in vollem gange und deswegen wurde jeder
konflikt in jeden winkel der welt von
den usa als gelegenheit gesehen den
einfluss der sowjetunion zu schwächen
außerdem war bekannt das ist in angola
erdölvorkommen
dies erklärt natürlich auch warum die
sowjetunion ebenfalls in diesem konflikt
mitspielen wollte sie unterstützte die
volksbewegung der befreiung anlass kurz
mpl
der langjährige anführer der mpm
bürgerkrieg war josé eduardo dos santos
dieser hatte zwar die maßgebliche
rückendeckung der sowjets aber
interessanterweise war das land das die
meiste unterstützung anbot
[Musik]
fidel castro begnügte sich nicht damit
dass santos waffen zu verkaufen er
entsandte gleich eine streitmacht von
30.000 soldaten nach angola
und nicht nur das in den 80er jahren
wurde der von der mpk kontrollierte teil
des landes medizinisch von koreanischen
ersten versorgt und die dortige
infrastruktur durch ingenieure aus
havanna aufgebaut dies war mit ein grund
warum dos santos schließlich als sieger
des bürgerkriegs hervorgehen tatsächlich
hatte dos santos schon während der 90er
jahre als die sowjetunion bereits
auseinander gefallen
die kämpfe in angola aber noch in vollem
gange waren bereits die kontrolle über
den überwiegenden teil des landes so
dass die kubanische entwicklungshilfe
auf breiter front vorangetrieben werden
konnte jetzt denkt ihr natürlich das so
engagierte entwicklungshilfe für ein der
leidgeplagten land wie angola doch eine
tolle sache sein muss
doch leider war der weg in die hölle so
oft auch hier mit guten absichten
gepflastert so versuchten zb die
landwirtschaftsexperten aus kuba im
großen stil und auf jede brachiale weise
wie wir sie vom kommunistischen regime
kennen auf biegen und brechen überall im
land zuckerrohr anzubauen
doch leider war das saatgut ganz und da
ungeeignet für die angolanischen bilden
[Musik]
in nur wenigen jahren schafften es die
inkompetenten entwicklungshelfer den
großteil des landwirtschaftlichen fläche
anlass zu vernichten und vollkommen
unfruchtbar zu machen
die folge waren grausame hungersnöte und
eine gewaltige wut der bevölkerung auf
die globale als wenn dies nicht schlimm
genug gewesen wäre dachte sich gerade
dos santos nach dem zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion wäre es plötzlich eine gute
idee auch mit ein paar kapitalistischen
ländern an zu wandeln schließlich
handelt es sich um diejenigen länder die
das angolanische öl kauft außerdem
stellten die usa die unterstützung der
unita
doch welche bedingungen muss das land
füllen um ein verbündeter der
sogenannten freien welt zu werden
nun eigentlich nur eine einzige das
schlagwort marxistisch aus seinem
vokabular entfernen und durch ein
anderes ersetzen demokratische
marktwirtschaft und ja ich habe dies mit
einem hauch von sarkasmus ausgesprochen
der angolanische kapitalismus sein
spezieller ist
demokratie auf angolanische das land
2002 war für angola eine wende ja
eduardo dos santos unterzeichnen da ein
friedensabkommen mit seinen widersachern
und aus der unita wurde eine normale
politische partei mit dem recht an
wahlen teilzunehmen
das erste mal überhaupt kamen angolaner
in den genuss demokratischer freude
die guten nachrichten rissen aber nicht
ab
wp entdeckt erstes tiefsee ölfeld vor
der küste angolas
über nacht war aus angola eine erdöl
großmacht geworden die tunnel von dino
sagt an china und die usa exportiert und
in nur fünf jahren gastierte sicht
erreichte man wohlers firmen wie exxon
mobil oder dp investierten in großem maß
an oder sie in sandten heerscharen von
ingenieuren und facharbeitern in die
angolanische hauptstadt luanda und diese
hochqualifizierten arbeitskräfte
erwarteten dort jene lebensstandard den
sie unterhalb gewohnt waren hochwertige
häuser coole bars und all die waren die
sie auch zu hause einzukaufen gewohnt
war
aber all diese dinge sind nicht so
einfach aufzutreiben in einem land das
vor kurzem durch einen grausamen
bürgerkrieg verwüstet worden
anders ausgedrückt das angebot war
äußerst begrenzt aber die nachfrage
hörte gar nicht auf zu wachsen
das ergebnis war ein exorbitanter
preisanstieg für westliche machen da
kommt aber noch mehr
stellt euch vor ihr hättet eine
chinesische baufirma und wolltet einen
wohnblock in luanda errichten
also als erstes müsstet ihr eine
niederlassung eures firma in angola
gründen und im handelsregister eintragen
lassen nicht wahr
nun dies könnte ihnen gerne ein halbes
jahr dauern und nehmen dessen ist es
vollkommen normal dass die behörden jede
menge probleme stoßen sie werden einen
hausens und bescheinigungen nachweisen
und auswertungen verlangen ihr wisst
schon welche art von auswertungen
gemeint sind jene die sich bequem
erledigen lassen indem ein ältesten
geldscheine oder dem schreibtisch in
eine verschwitzte beamten oder politiker
gewandelt berichten von organisationen
wie transparency international zufolge
war so gut jedes unternehmen das in
angola tätig werden wollte gezwungen
regierungsmitarbeiter
das war jedoch nur die spitze des
eisbergs all jene ölfirmen wie exxon
mobil oder bpd und dollar investieren
wollten hatten noch eine zusätzliche
auslage sie durften nur über joint
ventures mit der regierung oder dem
staatsunternehmen sonangol tätig werden
isabel dos santos reichster frau hat
angola abgezockt isabel dos santos kam
an lukrative deals mittelland diamanten
und telekommunikationsunternehmen als
ihr vater präsident von angola war einem
land im südlichen afrika das reich an
natürlichen ressourcen ist
die dokumente zeigen wie sie sich und
ihre mann staatsvermögen zuschanzte frau
dos santos war 2016 dank eines
präsidialen lasten ihres vaters josé
eduardo dos santos der sein land während
der 38 jahre die einer macht war fest im
griff hatte mit der leitung der sonangol
betraut worden
und damit wäre auch erklärt wie sie ist
so kurzer zeit die reichste frau europas
werden
zu jedem größeren investment das dos
santos in angola hat besitzt ist sie
entweder dadurch gekommen dass sie an
einer firma die in diesem land
geschäftlich aktiv sein wollte beteiligt
wurde oder dadurch dass der präsident
die per federstrich an den geschäften
beteiligt hat
während dieser ganzen zeit verbot ihr
vater internationalen journalisten den
zugang ins land ringos die meisten
korruptionsskandale in angola über die
wir bescheid wissen wurden durch die
regierungen großbritanniens und der usa
aufgedeckt in einem solchen politischen
klima war natürlich kaum ein angolaner
bereits selbst unternehmerisch aktiv zu
werden schließlich konnte man sich nur
als millionär die exorbitanten
bestechungsgelder leistung
[Musik]
und selbst wenn man die kosten durch
korruption vernachlässigen würde führt
allein die kafkaeske bürokratien angola
dazu dass die formalitäten zur eröffnung
einer einfachen bahn mehr als 1000
dollar verschlingen und 1000 dollar sind
in einem armen land wie angola ein
vermögen aber nicht nur die
einheimischen haben die schnauze voll
ebenso ist kein ausländisches
unternehmen bereits in angola mehr zu
investieren als das absolute minimum
dass man eben braucht und öl aus der
erde zu pumpen
so ist fragst du dich sicher welche
folgen hat das alles nun das ergebnis
ist schlicht und einfach dass angola
nichts anderes als erdöl exportiert
während des letzten jahrzehnts wurde die
gesamte wirtschaftsleistung des landes
von öl sollte anlagen und dem bau von
firmen wohnungen der darin beschäftigten
nominiert im jahre 2014 bedruckte anteil
von erdöl an den exporten angolas sage
und schreibe 97 prozent vielleicht
konnte er das jetzt durchaus bekannt vor
wenn du schon länger visual politik
verfolgt fällt der sich ja der name
eines ganz bestimmten landes ein dass
eine ganz ähnliche vollkommen einseitige
wirtschaftsstruktur aufweist venezuela
und das gleiche schicksal dass das land
in denen nicolas maduro waltet er alte
als der ölpreis einbrach traf auch
angola mit voller härte
aber lasst uns mal kurz zu unserem
beispiel mit der chinesischen baufirma
zurückkehren
denn es waren gerade besonders viele
chinesische unternehmen die millionen
investierten in die errichtung ganz
anderer stadtteile viel ausländischen
fachkräfte doch zusammen mit den
petrodollars versiegte auch dieser strom
und investitionsgelder schneller als
gedacht
kurz gesagt die ganze geschichte kennt
nur zwei sieger jose eduardo dos santos
und seine tochter isabel die ihre
enormen profite rechtzeitig im ausland
angelegt hat die meisten großen foto
giesen firmen von gulp des uni tel
werden nun dieser familien kosten
die ehemalige kolonialmacht portugal ist
für geld waschmaschine angolas geworden
die angolanischen eliten schafften
schätzungsweise 190 milliarden us-dollar
aus dem land und während das ganze land
von einer krise in die nächste taumelt
und sind 'raus versinkt posiert isabel
dos santos die sich auf ihrem
twitter-account als unternehmerin
bezeichnet mit allerlei promis wie zum
beispiel kim kardashian
doch vielleicht nicht mehr lange denn
der wind fängt an sich gegen dos santos
zu drehen ist ein bonner gericht
beschlagen aktien im wert von 444
millionen dollar im besitz von isabel
dos santos
[Musik]
ein istanbuler gericht hat eine 26
prozentige beteiligung an der
portugiesischen telekommunikationsfirma
ndoors von einer holding-gesellschaft
beschlagnahmt die sich im besitz von
isabel dos santos befindet der tochter
des ehemaligen angolanischen präsidenten
angeblich reichste frau afrika ist
angolanische gerichte haben im dezember
das vermögen von dos santos zusammen mit
denen er das man ist eingefroren nachdem
behauptet wurde dass die beiden an
geschäften mit staatseigenen unternehmen
beteiligt waren durch welche der staat
1,14 milliarden dollar verlor im februar
ordnete die portugiesische
staatsanwaltschaft zudem die
beschlagnahme der bankkonten der ex
präsidenten tochter alle die auch
anteile an mehreren anderen produkten
unternehmen besitzt darunter der
ölkonzern teilt und wer jetzt aber meint
die familie dos santos würde dies
irgendwie zum nachgeben bewegen ehrt
gewaltig
[Musik]
isabel dos santos geht nun zum
gegenangriff über während sich der rest
der welt auf die auswirkungen der neuen
corona virus pandemie konzentriert ist
die ehemalige erste tochter angolas
isabel dos santos mehr besorgt über die
beschlagnahme ihres ehemaligen
geschäftsimperium es durch die
justizbehörden sie bezeichnete die
jüngste beschlagnahme von 26 prozent des
aktienkapitals des
telekommunikationsbetreiber snus als
missbrauch die empörung von frau dos
santos schoss sich auf die tatsache zu
konzentrieren dass die behörden ihres
heimatlandes wo sie wegen betrugs und
unterschlagung strafrechtlich verfolgt
wird das ihnen angeblich von ihm
geschuldete geld mehr als eine milliarde
euro bereits beschlagnahmt haben tja und
mit einem juristischen sieg wird sich
bis appell dos santos noch lange nicht
zufrieden geben
ganz und gar nicht sie will die ganze
macht ihrer familie über angola
wiederherstellen
[Musik]
isabel dos santos afrikas reichste frau
nimmt kurs auf das präsidialamt die in
einen riesigen finanz skandal
verwickelte angolanische milliardär ist
appel dos santos hat angedeutet dass sie
sich um die präsidentschaft des landes
bemühen will die hat jegliches
fehlverhalten bestritten
dies sind falsche anschuldigungen und
teil eines orchestrierten angriffs der
gegenwärtigen regierung der vollständig
politisch motiviert ist sagte sie sie
betonte wiederholt dass er leben in
gefahr seit wenn sie unter den
gegenwärtigen umständen nach angola
zurückkehren würde da sie aber ein
ausgeprägtes gefühl von patriotismus und
pflichtbewusstsein gegenüber ihrem
heimatland habe lehnte sie es strikt ab
ihre kandidatur für das präsidentenamt
auszuschließen
[Musik]
an cola lehnt eu wahlbeobachter ab es
stellt sich also vor allem die frage ob
angola sich überhaupt eines tages ihrer
korrupten führungsschicht entledigen
kann wird es in der lage sein in die
fussstapfen jeder afrikanischen löwen
die ghana oder honda zu treten schreibt
uns im kommentarbereich was eher bedeckt
filme möchten wir euch mit aller kraft
dazu ermuntern unseren kanal zu
abonnieren damit ihr ja keines unserer
informativen videos passt und wie immer
auf wiedersehen im nächsten video
[Musik]